[Music]
wherever i go in this country certainly
and i actually tested it overseas in
bulgaria i always i consistently get a
laugh for the following line which is
not
which is the truth it's not a joke
i have
christian and i both have an uncle named
dick long
and well dick his name is dick yes his
last name is long right what did i say
dick long
yeah it's not one name his name isn't
dick long long that that'd be
that you'd get a bigger laugh
yeah that'd be pretty gang as the kids
say gangsta kids say that now well
adults say too cooler adults okay that's
what i meant
not like nerdy 43 year olds
but uh have you ever heard the term
downstroke no oh it's a great term it's
like in punk music the first chord is a
downstroke and so there's instead of
saying like that's punk that's punk rock
it's down stroke it's like well that's
uh it's really like leaning into
something i'm gonna start using that oh
yeah you know i think what's punk rock
is
that's the whole story oh yeah let's not
push the story that's a [ __ ]
downstroke yeah right speaking of punk
rock life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i am
your um gangsta host whoa
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
this feels like an appropriation oh
gangster
you're not a gangster either yeah what
are you talking about
it's hard not to appropriate some
culture
you're we're done you're abortion you're
more
you're more bugsy siegel than
you are
tupac yeah
yes
uh you're closer to bugsy i don't know i
don't know uh
wait a minute i mean you're so far from
both of them
no physically of course i'm closer to
bugsy siegel i'm only picturing warren
beatty i don't know you're not bugsy
siegel looks pretty have you ever seen a
picture of him yeah he's you look at
nothing like him i bet two people in
color you have the same skin color you
think my features are closer to tupac
tupac was very handsome i i know i wish
i looked more like tupac i'd rather look
more like tupac than warren beatty in
fact wow well warren beatty has um i
don't know warren beatty's
yeah he's pretty we talk about how
good-looking guys are way too much on
the show who cares cares all right well
we're also talking about dicks not dicks
but our uncle dick yeah he's a dick and
by the way he's not a dick he's he's
really great he's great and he's um all
of our uncles are very funny we're
blessed to have funny we do also side
note uncle dick dick long long comma
dick our uncle dick is
our teammate on family feud rich rich
long for people who saw that that's his
dad yes and rich was very funny on the
show yeah you so you can see rich is
very funny in life yes yeah he but he he
had a few like real zingers on the show
he got a few things that got cut out
yeah i know i know um dick just came of
age in a time where that name dick
was very common it wasn't every tom dick
and harry that was the expression there
was a very that's how common it was yeah
it's part of an expression that means
common
uh refers to a commonality but i think
even when he was named the word dick
still referred to male genitalia do you
think i don't know when that became oh
maybe i'm wrong how can i just assumed i
don't know how the two would coexist how
did that how did a penis i've thought i
thought about become a dick i i have
thought about that way too often i don't
know well we should try to figure should
research that a little bit shorties sure
it it's interesting because it it
couldn't have been uh as common it
couldn't have been a penis name back
then or at least a common penis name uh
here's another fact about um uncle dick
is that i know he enjoys a nice cold
beer yes
but i've also
never to my memory seen him drunk
no he's a very moderate person as as is
our other uncle uncle tim who's also
very tall
he brews his own beer very funny i've
never seen him drunk either there was
also a movie called fun with dick and
jane that's right fun with dick and jane
maybe a great adult title would just
remove the anne jane
so uncle dick is not a drunk uncle no to
us but some uncles are drunk i'm sure he
has been drunk i'm sure we should talk
to him but i don't want to shame him for
it he the point is he doesn't have an
issue with substance abuse here's the
larger point why are we talking about
drunk uncles i'll tell you why because
our guest today is
the very funny bobby moynihan who's
maybe best known character uh is drawn
kunkel he's on snl yes that's right um
that was a key part of the introduction
that i missed i think most people would
connect it because they know bobby
moynihan from snl man bobby is one of
those um
performers who just commits a hundred
percent and
there's no better example of that than
his drawing clinical character who uh we
talk about today i i was really curious
about the origin of that
character i always am about where
you know characters come from but um you
like a good committer i do i do and he
commits with the best of them he sure
does he was on snl for nine years i
believe yes and we talk about this too
but he's so good speaking of committed
performances he is so good in this movie
um
uh sisters i think with the amy poehler
movie and i should know the name if i'm
going to reference it uh where he plays
this
he plays an unfunny guy a guy who thinks
he's funny and he steals the movie
and to do that from amy poehler and tina
fey is a real feat um and then he gets
he does like a ton of cocaine later at
this part anyway it's it's just one i
it's one of the funniest performances
i've ever seen ever it's he's so good in
it but um he's always so good and he
plays on snl he played a lot of like
really over-the-top characters that were
felt like real like
a little bit like reminds me a little
bit of cecily strong yes um friend of
the show yeah in that they found such
specific specificity
in their characters but and they like
did big things but it all felt so real
he always felt very real to me yeah
likewise you don't both have to think
bobby moynihan's commitment to his
characters is real he now has a uh a new
show an animated show that he created
yes tarzan called loafy
about a um a manatee who sells pot and
side note this might sells pot god i saw
an old man you don't sound like gangsta
it is so hard for me i for someone who
like really
see uses a lot of weed i almost said
uses a lot of weed it's impossible for
me to talk about that without sounding
uncool i know we've talked about that
but it's it it remains true yes
uh well anyway do you know what else
remains true what my excitement about
our guest today
i would like to hear this i i would too
even though i was there for it i want to
re-listen and i hope that you all want
to just listen for the first time to my
catch-up with the very funny the
committed hilarious bobby moynihan
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
bobby where are you uh i'm in a friend's
barn no i'm in my i'm in my house um
oh my god i really i would have believed
you
uh it's very white there yes it's a very
white right now yeah it's a pure white
room we get our furniture like next week
oh oh nice oh how exciting uh you would
uh
first of all i am so sorry
i i'm glad i get to look at you when i
do this now because uh i swear oh man
you you uh thank you for we can't bailed
on you and um it was uh i loved what you
said you were like oh i'm just like
playing with my dog
my daughter it's just more time to play
with her which sounds awesome yes it was
it was great
yeah how old is she now four do you just
do characters now for her is it just
like playing
i'm just imagining how fun you must be
it's been a lot of playing i'm a pl it's
been a lot of playing i still play i
play more than she does uh but um
yeah i don't
where
it's a lot of like dada your rainbow
dash from little pony
oh she has you oh she does the casting
she does the blocking she does
everything
and then and i do it and i do it uh no
matter what
i bet the bar
has been set so high for with somebody
like you because you're so gifted at
characters and likes what you do for a
living
and she's going to be around other kids
and like their parents are gonna you
know oh it's so weird it's it's a mess
already in in that sense in the sense of
like
yes she'll go to like like well before
the pandemic when we would go to like my
gym or like one of those like places
where you jump around and like they have
toys and stuff like
it's boring because like that
my garage looks like looks like a
children's toys
because you're also i mean i you've
talked a lot about being feeling like
you were like a fan you were like a fan
of uh star wars all these things
yeah i'm a fan of things yeah
that's a terrible way to phrase that no
i am i do yeah i think it's actually a
great way to put it so you still have
all that i mean i have a lot of masters
of of the universe revelation question
oh oh right yeah oh we got to get into
it well you're friends with all those
masters of the universe is that kevin so
kevin smith's doing the new
he-man uh i was just you know mentioning
my the nerdiest thing i knew about you
right right off the bat oh oh yeah well
it's pretty nerdy although i wasn't were
you into that when you were a kid i was
i wasn't really human uh i was i was sue
i was very into human oh really
yeah
yeah yeah see because star wars felt
like it was the same time as star wars
and it felt like those two worlds
clashed to me for some reason i i don't
know why i went right into transformers
from stuff got it uh the cartoons the
he-man the he-man the cartoons i i
actually i may have like found star wars
later kenner toys were like my
introduction to star yeah
do you remember seeing the movie because
we're about the same age do you remember
seeing
are you younger than me so you may have
missed empire strikes back there's no
way i'm younger than you there's no way
oh well i'm 44.
oh i'm 63.
nice
oh okay yeah uh i'm i just turned 43.
okay so you're we're about the same so
you just say i think i'm older i look
like i look like a sweet boy but you
do
you do it was always so funny that's
what i loved about seeing you playing
older people because you'd have this
like old hair like drawing uncles just
like gray hair but you had this kind of
like
there's nothing i love more my dream i
mean you should have seen me pandemic
bobby i was my dream is christopher
lloyd like just yes wild wild white on
camera just do whatever yeah
i remember seeing this maybe on
instagram that you had like a gandalf
fest you had like a wizardy beard yes i
had a very long beard for the for the
pandemic i went for it it was it was
glorious is it weird for your wife to
kiss a beard
i mean you want me to get her
no i'm just gonna
um she probably couldn't be honest in
front of you
we haven't kissed yet uh okay okay okay
done everything else i will let you know
um oh please fingers crossed figures
funny
14 years we've been together 14 years oh
man i'm rooting for you you're gonna
love it it's uh i'm hoping for 15. well
i didn't know that she was a broadway
she was a theater actor yeah yeah yeah
and is that how you guys met uh
scandalous we uh
we met the ucb she uh
she was in my improv class i was her
improv teacher but we didn't start
dating until afterwards i was a good
teacher
oh yeah
i did that as
as you stroke your beard
it's good for that i guess it's good to
yeah it's good to have like a move um
and you did i didn't realize you did ucb
for that long for i mean you were doing
it for quite so people always think as
did i that snl
you know is your first thing and you
kind of come out of nowhere and
um no no i was uh ucb 2000 i started
wow um
and i got snl 2008 i think oh wow man
was that just a natural you loved it
since you were a kid
uh yeah seth meyers when i got the show
the night i got the show i saw that or
maybe it was like the weekend i got the
show i saw seth meyers and he said
congratulations uh you'll never talk
about anything else again for the rest
of your life but i was like i i remember
laughing at the time but it's it is it
is completely true
every conversation gets there it's
bonkers um i'm sure even with friends
i'm sure even with like
you run into people from
school or whatever people i mean you
must find the same thing but like yeah
you know it was funny i would find more
with like without close people it was
people going like how do i get tickets
like that's what
but uh but um yeah i imagine there are
two different versions now you even said
like what the time i i mean at the time
you laugh it off i'm sure but in
retrospect what would you say to that
bobby like the like the you know the the
like the eager you're on snl and like
somebody says something like that with
you and there's there's like a degree of
cynicism in that
yeah i mean like one of i think one of
the hardest pills to swallow and like i
thought that that's terrible thing to
say i have a very amazing life i'm very
pleased and happy with it but with snl
like that that thing was like
the the thing for me that was confusing
with it was being told like well you
just act like you're a star just act
like you got it you know like that's it
you did it like now just act that way
and i was even more terrified than
before but it was like i think that's
what i would tell myself is like
after i got the job like then i should
have just had fun and enjoyed it because
like everything after that was just
instead of being in my head so much oh
for so many years of just like oh god am
i gonna get fired am i gonna get fired
like i should have told myself even if i
do it doesn't matter i was on snl for
five seconds like i know but it's hard
it's easier said than done i guess when
you're in it everyone i know on that
show has a version of that oh everybody
has their journey i'm very happy very
pleased with where i am on the on this
side at this point well bobby three
years out
i bet um
you especially having a kid i mean like
that also must put throw everything into
into perspective you have a kid i know
you went through i i
certainly don't have to talk about it
but i know you went through a lot of
like personal
oh yeah tragedy during that time and
like you know soon after i murdered a
bunch of people you yes you murdered and
you got caught that's the bummer of it
all uh that's the only thing i'm upset
about
[Laughter]
but you um
but you had said that keenan i just want
to like because this this struck me that
keenan was the one was the guy or at
least the guy that you knew well enough
that was um
that was just made for that was just
made for us and now had the bandwidth
for it
and and said something to you like you
know just let it
let everything roll off your back i i
really admire that
his
i think the angriest i ever saw keenan
at work in my nine years there which is
by the way not even half his time there
what how long has he been there he will
i think he j well he
he wants to hit 20 he said nine i think
he's been there
18 years night oh my god
like that's nuts man that's amazing
strange that's it he's been doing it his
whole life yeah yeah yeah
yeah he was just like
the angriest i ever saw him was like a
joke he didn't like he was like really
that we're gonna do oh
like
that was like the most upset i ever saw
him that's amazing that's amazing that
that to me is like it's funny you
mentioned kevin smith and like i've been
and i also heard you say something like
off the cuff about having smoked too
much weed and you're not remembering
things um and i as you said that it was
like i don't remember
are you right
but i was struggling to remember things
myself and um
and every time i see keenan you know the
after show people are
going to those after parties there's
always like an air of um
there's still some nerves in the air
it's still like
well and also just socializing with
people like that in that capacity it's
like kind of
keenan has always been like
so [ __ ] chill like weirdly chill
well yeah i mean like he that i think
like it's just
if if if there's any way to like
the key to life is keenan thompson is
just like simplify everything it's just
like ain't this isn't this nice we have
a job
is it like
is it isn't it nice we have a family i'm
gonna go home to them when this job is
over yeah yeah i know how and it's just
like it's just and he's very good at
just
that and like he's but but also he's
become something very different since
like the moment i left like it was like
keenan went
like it's like like everything like he
all of a sudden he was on that show and
like you know
now it's a very different vibe at snl
like when i was there we were trying to
write sketches every week now it's like
you know they're also have their own
shows and they're on other shows and
they're like you know
it wasn't necessarily like that in my
that's true there weren't as many
certainly nearly as many platforms i
guess for that stuff now it's like um
when i first started andy was like
they're putting one of my sketches on
this thing called youtube and i was like
what the [ __ ] is youtube
that's like andy sandberg like that's
the one who told me what it was
that wasn't the great day well you're in
the great day one
uh yeah i was in a car i mean that was
like my first year was like
i have a very distinct memory of my
first episode the the uh the the one was
space olympics and uh i was i wasn't in
it and i remember watching it going like
that was amazing and then like it
dawning on me like i might be in that
like in one of those next week and like
i remember like
it's it's fanboy like like all this
right here in space
right you've described yourself that way
i was that way growing up i'm like
same age we grew up i grew up dana
carvey and mike myers and all that um
we were in a sketch together yes yes
were we we both played like matthew
mcconaughey
yes that's right that's right um am i
crazy
no no it was a ghost sketch and i
remember um
god i had just the tiniest i mean maybe
it was heightened for me because i only
i got to do like you know how sometimes
when you just have like one or two lines
and something it's like oh that's the
worst stakes oh it's the scariest and
like stakes are so high and it's like
you have one line to do it well and so
yeah i had that one line and i think i
was just like
i think maybe two in my head about it
and it was an impression that i had done
a bunch and um i immediately felt like
oh i want to do it again oh that's yeah
and then have that feeling for the rest
of your life because you can't
[Laughter]
that must be fun every week for nine
years yeah i don't know how i seriously
sometimes like i i kanan's just built
different like he just like they'd be
like your sketch is cut he was like
like
and you're just like all right
but bobby we're i think he was just
better at handling it i think he just
had been in the business and he's just a
very good guy he's a good man well i
mean yeah you heard you mentioned i've
been doing this as well i recently got
into meditation and um
do you ever wish like god the tools that
you have now or the things that you're
cultivating do you wish that you
had those while you were on the show i
mean oh a billion percent i i
one person like during like a very like
chaotic
night
at snl
uh one person said did you ever just
think about getting therapy and i
remember being like are you [ __ ] like
like i i snapped like i triggered like i
went like are you crazy
like me
like i went like i went i went nuts
that's funny
i mean it's tragic but it's funny you
think i need therapy i was like it's
that's [ __ ] tight like it's like
like i went nuts i was like you're
blaming me you're not the institution of
saturday night like uh i wish i had gone
that night
that person was very very very right
yeah yeah well i that person whoopi
goldberg
that's what i thought
sounds like a whoopee thing to do
but i do but lastly i but of course
drawing uncle must be the thing that
comes up the most
right in terms of saturn live yeah yeah
so probably yeah
and when i think of you i think of um
i think of like somebody who really
commits to things and drunk uncles an
example of that but i i think
specifically of of the part you played
in sisters uh
which is to me one of the i think i may
have texted you about this i meant to i
was going to say that that that in in
all
in in all of this leading to this that
that text was like i think about it
often it was just a very
nice thing to do and a very kind like
that people don't normally do that and
it was wonderful and
i i still remember it to this day it was
yeah that was the coolest oh man and
also being a fan it's also just like in
that thing of you go like oh that's
that's right these
we we watch everyone else's stuff and
it's fun and it's wonderful oh it is i
was i was a fan of yours but when i saw
that i i i said it i i meant to
articulate it you're doing something in
that that is like on a level of i think
about like martin short i think about
guys who
um
really dana carvey like commit in um
with everything you you were i there was
a it was a brilliant uh it was real i me
i really meant that i mean that that's
that's amazing martin short is like i
mean seeing seeing that man in person
was like oh
i i i can't i can't even like he was put
on this earth to entertain
somebody hit an on switch and i never
never turned it off thank god like but
also sweet like not that might sound
annoying you know i know there's in fact
like your character and sisters like
that's like the annoying
version of that
yeah and humorless version
but martin short is like is is he not
like i've heard that he's just the
nicest
in addition to being the most
entertaining it's it's it's that that
he's a he's a person like like a magical
little sprite like when you like like
put put aside being like a super fan of
snl and all that stuff and being on the
show but like
to just be like walking down
i was walking down the hall one night
and just like
my i don't know if you've been at snl
that top floor like near the studio like
you you right where you go in the studio
you get there's a huge window where you
can see the entire studio yes and uh
uh
right right off to the side is my
dressing room door and like
it never gets lost on me i was turned in
the corner and i looked through the
studio door and i was just like oh man
this place i guess like holy christ like
just like literally having a moment of
just like i can't believe this and i
opened my dressing room door and
my dressing room and martin short martin
short just pops up out of my couch like
how dare you i just started screaming
that's amazing immediately screaming at
me and scolding me and then like within
five seconds it's like i'm kidding sit
down sit down sit down and i'm just like
what is happening like
that's was that your first season no no
i think that was a little bit later it
was like had to be like one of the five
timers club he was using my he was using
my dressing room for something and my
god
but it was just like that that
that stuff would happen that stuff you
turn a corner and like paul mccartney's
there and he's like you want pizza and
you're just like
yeah wow yeah i want to see paul
mccartney
does it begin to erode any like any kind
of like
celebrity weirdness that you have
because everyone has like
i mean unless you're like keenan and you
grow up in it like but for the most part
people are have that weird relationship
with
celebrities and famous people but does
it start to demystify that a little bit
or does it enhance it
i remember like uh it was like a couple
years in
jim carrey hosted and it's like
you start to get oh you start to get a
little numb you start to get like a
little numb with people and jimmy's like
who's this week yeah and or like
i
that's a whole nother story that was a
cool thing where it was like who's this
i i can i i think i can
i i have i'm comfortable saying this out
loud i was like who's this week adam
levine like all right yeah and then it
was like and then adam levine shows up
and you're like whoa this dude is
the best like this dude is like he was
super down to do everything like he was
so funny he's come back a couple times
like he's
you did it you did a digital short with
him right uh he's been in a couple
things that i wrote like he he came back
and
i wrote this thing with taran uh
called uh
a standoff where it was like me me taryn
and jeremy renner were guys like
pointing guns at each other like in a
stand oh yeah and then the whole thing
was that jeremy renner had to go pick
his kid up from school and like we just
went through his day and like with guns
pointed but at one point we ran
at one point we just run into adam
levine and he pulls out two guns too
and he just asks for directions but like
yeah he would like like i remember that
week being like meh but he like turned
out to be awesome and like i've i've
spoken to him a few times since the
show's over like and that
sort of stuff was insane
well but it probably reveals that like
you forget that everyone reveres snl the
way the way we probably did growing up
or for the most part especially
entertainers like that's been an
institution so long so i'm sure somebody
like adam levine is like thinks the way
similarly to the way i do or you do is
like yeah i want to do something on
there it's snl yeah or like sometimes
you go like oh this person's a musician
or something they're not going to be
great like i remember bruno mars like i
was like oh okay like i know i i know
bruno mars this will be fun he's he
seems he has a lot of energy
and then like he killed it like just
killed him right i have a i have a
memory of being in that sketch where he
was singing
in that sketch where he was doing like a
bunch of impressions and the audience
just being like the place was literally
rock yeah like yeah that's
he does incredible impress yeah people
that like would surprise ariana grande i
remember seeing her like incredible they
did like a similar sketch yes yes they
did like they brought that sketch back
with her and did it like the same thing
that he did yeah
doesn't that make you feel like uh oh
[ __ ] you can do that too it's like i
thought that's that was what i did you
know
uh right yeah no i was never good at
impressions a singing or impression not
but not my bag i i i like to be um
she'll be weird dudes
i've heard you say that but like i've
heard you do i think it's george lucas
i get lucky sometimes george lucas is
fun but like it's more like i just
happen to look exactly like him and same
thing with snooki and guy fieri i'm
vaguely italian
yeah but even guy fury like i don't know
i think i don't think you're giving
yourself enough credit there is um you
capture in essence to those people it's
similar to what dana carvey did which is
like oh yeah that's not exactly ross
perot but like that is ross bro that's
like
you've you've captured and committed to
an essence of them i i shouldn't be as
down on myself as i am but like when you
work with people like daryl hammond and
jay farrow and like right even cecily
like cecily's a very underrated like
like with her with her things tara and
kill him too like oh my god but like you
would walk up to kate and just be like
hey can you do this and she would go
like
yep i could do it and you're good like
son of a [ __ ]
i bet i bet one of my most embarrassing
moments like if like if when i think
back of snl was uh just like they they
said hey we wrote this thing where
you're playing rudy giuliani and i
remember just being like nope
not this week not this week nope
oh really not gonna do it and they were
like you're playing rudy giuliani it's
easy it's easy just do it and
just do the penguins it was like
but see like that's the thing like like
yeah that's the thing that's exactly
what i should have done
but like i i went like i i i was like hi
i'm rudy giuliani and like just like
didn't give a [ __ ] because i didn't want
to i didn't want to do because i knew
like i was like hey like how many people
have done an amazing rudy i think that's
kate ended up doing like i was just like
no way no i i yeah but i wish i had
tried or i wish i had just had fun like
that right right like taking a page out
of kenan's playbook and just like just
give you know your honest and i see that
would that kind of monday morning
quarterbacking would kill me because i
would do that i would i would i would be
afraid to commit because if you commit
it's you have to
it might you might fail you know well
there was just so much pressure and so
much like want
to like but i'm also but like but like i
was at ucb for 10 years getting ready
for saturn in their lives so here's my
suit salesman character
and then all of a sudden they're like
you have to audition for trump but i'm
like i don't want to play trump like oh
my god
[Music]
you look healthy and
you look less stressed i appreciate you
noticing do you know why well i you s
you had told me you were getting more
sleep i was but do you know why no do
you know how is it the plus cbd yes i
know i've been taking them too i love
these things and these things you pop
them before you go to but they're
delicious first of all these gummies are
fantastic oh man you wake up feeling
focused and refreshed turns out they're
formulated by a team of medical experts
and doctors i've tried the calm gummies
i've tried the sleep gummies and last
night for the first time i tried the
reserve collection gummies which is a
life is short exclusive the reserve
collection is a specially curated blend
of full-spectrum cannabinoids that
celebrates our very first batch of plus
cbd oil they're rich in bold they're
reserved collection gummies with 25
milligrams of cbd and 2.5 milligrams of
thc these are your mothers no sleep
dummies you got you got some fun stuff
in there actually they might be your
mother's sleep companies they should be
good for mom sure elicit feelings of
calm and relief when intense support is
needed i took one last night
and
man intense support was neat do they
work yeah you were really calm and
relieved seeming visit plus cbd oil.com
and enter promo code long for 40
off your order
hey life is short listeners wonder is
even the rich podcast is doing a
two-part series on the bizarre and
fascinating kidnapping of patty hurst
and you won't want to miss it
one night in 1974 19 year old college
student patty hearst who happened to be
the heir to their hearst newspaper
fortune was kidnapped from her berkeley
apartment she was kept in a closet for
weeks while her captors made their
demands then after two months in
captivity in a completely unexpected
twist patty announced that her name was
tanya and was seen on video robbing a
bank with her captors the new season of
even the rich explores different
theories about what actually happened to
patty was she brainwashed or was she the
victim of stockholm syndrome listen to
even the rich on apple podcasts amazon
music or you can listen one week early
and add free by joining wondering plus
in the wondery app
hello hello again
[Music]
you talked about the feeling of not
like committing to something the
giuliani moment but like do you have
the opposite feeling when you then do
commit and and it like it works like
something like drunk uncle when you
when you when that's just like a thing
you're trying out and it and it and it
really kills
does it feel what does it feel like i
don't know what it is to be on an iconic
platform and just kill that the the
second time the second time i did
drunk uncle
i remember feeling like a little like
all right i hope this works because i
did it once and i hope it works again
and when they said drunk uncle and
people were like yeah like we're excited
like we remember this and i was like
it's
yeah what like and i remember that that
second drunk uncle being like
i was i was a little i had like
i had like 50 extra like yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah there's i mean there's there's
hundreds of moments on snl that that i
play over and wish i could go back but i
i think i honestly think i'm in a in a a
much better place about it now than ever
i bet but uh i bet
it's uh is it now fun to look back is it
like is it is it fun to pick out the
moments of you know to kind of reflect
on you you had mentioned jim carrey
you're about to say something about oh
yeah well that that was that was like
you start to get numb like i think that
was like a year or two in
and then all of a sudden it was like you
know the pitch meeting and it was like
uh you know ladies and gentlemen carrie
and jim carrey
when they said jim carrey he like stood
up and like started going like
like he wanted and he was just being
very jim carrey and i went like really
big like i just went like holy [ __ ]
like i just lost it like it was like my
entire like the moment i remember
sitting in the movie theater and seeing
him kick that box in ace ventura and i
remember being like
what am i like what is this movie like
what am i about yeah i remember like
being like
that first jim carrey week being like
slapped in the face with like oh yeah
this job is [ __ ] crazy
yeah it's funny taryn cited him
specifically too is like that was a
moment of
i can't believe we're playing in the
sandbox with this a guy like this one of
one of the coolest things i ever got to
see at snl two was that week was uh
seeing taran
hold his own with jim carrey in that
sketch where they're the robots
yeah and just being like man this [ __ ]
like this show is bonkers like me and
taran had a couple couple really good
years of like
complete
childhood fantasy sketches of like just
getting to play in these like universes
that we loved with like
it it was an amazing thing but like i i
remember that week too and that
halloween sketch they did they were
great together you're also similarly
wired you have similar uh there's a
child-like and i mean that in the best
way there's a you're able to mine in
innocence like a really child wonder a
stupidity
yeah yes i couldn't put my finger on it
a refusal to grow
yes arrested in development uh
no but you you you both seem like you
have
a joy that's why i miss you both on that
show because there was
whatever you were doing there always
seemed you did it um that's why it's
interesting to hear you talk about the
giuliani moment because my impression of
you is always that
has been that you really commit to
things you you were you you're fearless
it was the last year it was my last year
on the show i was done like it was like
whenever they asked you to do an
impression or something i immediately
was like [ __ ] like
because there's like no one there there
was no one that you you were like i'm
comfortable like if you you said george
lucas you having to look like i had to
like
like everything i wanted to do people
were like
that's a little weird
like i would always
like i'm carrie fisher and they were
like yeah i don't know and i was like
i'm danny devito and they were like
that's a friend to lauren like it was
like
or like you know like i'm george lucas
and it was like yeah enjoy he knows
lauren too like it was like i always oh
my god weird messenger i remember kathy
bates i asked to play kathy bates once
and they were like nope like you're
kidding but that
four examples i gave just happened to be
all lauren's friends those were terrible
examples yeah or good but i would be
like could i be penn gillette and
they're like you're wendy the snapple
lady and i'm like right
[Laughter]
yeah
and who was your snl guy who was like
your
who's your favorite probably like farley
phil hartman yeah bill murray obviously
you know dan aykroyd's like
the first year dan aykroyd just like
he's just he's like bill hader like he's
just like every single thing
there's just people who can do
everything like kristen and kristen and
kate and cecily to me those guys are
savants they're like yeah it's scary
yeah
mike myers like you know like i forget
how how influential mike myers was i i
know i know and how different how
hit the spectrum of characters that he
played too to go from like
simon like the little kid in the tub to
like sprockets like he was really
versatile
i loved him
was there a moment bobby when you would
hear the like the satin and bobby moyn
and found pardo announcing your voice
was there a moment where you like i know
there was a moment where you were when
you first heard it it was like holy [ __ ]
well the first one i burst into tears
like but i was waiting for it because
like i couldn't believe it yeah it was
not but it but it never got old it never
got away oh really that's what i wanted
the greatest one ever and he has since
passed he was the greatest in his booth
that he had
for hundreds of years uh
he had all of our names
written
in his handwriting spelled out
phonetically with like these weird
symbols like he had like it was it was a
lot
he just walked past me he didn't talk a
lot he walked past me and he just went
he had a cup of coffee in his hand he
just went
bobby moynihan
such a fun name to say
not like that [ __ ] nightmare naseem
padrad
and he just kept walking
and i guess he had a hard time with the
scene's name but
and it was the greatest one of the
greatest moments of that's
that story i know the trials the
tribulations you must have had but
that's kind of what
how quickly did you tell them to seem
that story
i i was about to say i don't know if i
ever have i'm sure i have i'm sure i
have but like oh man oh the best
i had a one moment of like
like what it must have felt like in that
pressure cooker and like with
lauren i was dating drew drew was
hosting at the time and and uh oh that's
right i remember we had gone out a
couple nights earlier with and she's
like i want you to meet lauren and
er because she was like he does so many
good impressions he did he's so good at
impressions and and he and he said who
do you do you know and i just remember
freezing oh yeah and it was a casual oh
god who do you do
to learn my i mean
every dinner table every single question
he has ever asked me in my life is the
hardest question i've ever had to answer
like he would be like how are you i'd be
like
why do you want to know
yeah yeah i know it's not casual i don't
want to just say fine because then i'm
the boring guy but but also there were
people there were people there who were
like lauren would be like how was your
weekend and they would be like great
what did you do and like
that was fine and that helped them and
that like you know i was not that person
ipad and nev and you never you were nine
years you never got to like no i i did i
i definitely have i think i have a great
relationship with lauren i could have
had a much ease i i held him on a
pedestal that i should have realized was
he he understood
on day one that i was a giant fan of his
and very thing
i should have i should have uh i i
should have understood i think yeah
um but yeah he he but i've spoke to him
i think more since i left you know than
any a lot of people there
oh wow that's cool he was wonderful yeah
he's the greatest i i feel very
comfortable now i would feel very
comfortable now emailing him because i
don't have his phone number
[Laughter]
you can email him and ask him his number
so i it was last question about drawing
uncle was he based on anyone was he
based on somebody that it felt very
specific it is that's what i thought i
didn't want to say that i thought it'd
be arrogant if i said are you doing me
but i always
i always
i thought
oh yeah no it's like do you know chris
gether yes yes
i used to do this bit for chris gethard
at ucb i i i didn't drink that much at
one point
no i don't drink at all
um but like uh
i would do this bit at the ucb like bar
mcmanus down the street from ucv
where i would just sit at the bar and
pretend to be hammered and just just
sing just constantly sing the song let
me clear my throat
but
no one no matter what no matter what
anybody said to me i wouldn't i would
just pretend i was crying very drunk
just going live
bro
i just like to just sing that song and i
don't know why like it was just a weird
[ __ ] thing i would do to make chris
kether laugh
that's really funny and then that
was like i think like when i got snl
they made us write down a bunch of names
of characters and like i didn't have
many and i wrote down i just wrote down
drunk uncle mike
i just wrote that down i just wrote down
like 20 names i was like i'll figure it
out later and
just in case like so at least i own it
and like jost was like hey i want to do
an update do you have anything and i
literally went to go look at that list
saw the name i saw the name drunk uncle
mike and i was like i don't know maybe
like a drunk uncle kind of thing like i
just said he was like and he was like
what do you mean and then like jost was
the one who was like
oh that's hilarious like an uncle like
at like thanksgiving and like then we
like an hour later we wrote it we wrote
it in an hour and i never thought about
it i was like we'll never do that one
that one was stupid wow really just
because it was so simple because it was
so like off the cuff
i should have known better it it rolled
off our tongue to me it was more like
also another thing about jost is like
you walk into joe's office at literally
5 30 6 in the morning like while he's
like getting ready to like sit on the
couch and like put a blanket over him to
go to bed for a little bit and he'll be
like he'll be like you want to write
something and i'll be like yeah what
about a drunk uncle and you'll say four
jokes and he'll go
all right i'll see you at noon and then
at noon well that's not true at 1 30
he'll come back with like a fully
written sketch and you're just like yeah
no this is it and that's exactly what
happened what wow and like so bright so
quick i remember the second we read it i
was like oh
i think we'll do that this week and then
like um now every time i pass that funko
funko pop of it i cry
yeah isn't that funny well yeah it's the
cool like that's like that that little
fan of me that little fanboy part of me
needs to
has grown up and moved on a little bit
which is nice
it was yeah but still but what is what
is that juggling act like when you you
have that the excitement still of that
and you still have like remnants of the
fan
in you that got to do that but then
there's the people yelling eh you're
drunk uncle
how do you navigate those situations i
think i'm like coming out of a tail end
period right now where like
i'm in a really nice spot where like i
haven't had like almost any saturday
night live in my life other than like
other than like
seeing the new episodes as a fan
but like just watching them and then
moving on like as entertainment um after
snl it was just it was i got married had
a baby went through a bunch of stuff and
then like
now with pandemic stuff it's been a lot
of start and stops but like the best
part has just been
going from
sleeping four hours a night for nine
years to
[Music]
doing that for like one year kind of but
like our daughter was a good sleeper so
it really wasn't that bad like so like
now like
my hours are insane my hours are like
four in the morning to eight pm and
that's it like oh my god and i'm and
productive i imagine
i've been well that's another thing too
was realizing like i think the little
kid in me was like snl is over what the
hell do i do now but now it's like
yeah i have a bunch of stuff coming out
that i'm really excited about like i
can't wait for people to see stuff that
sounds that you've created you created
loafie um it's a cartoon but it's not
one that your daughter can watch it
sounds like incredible he's a man she's
a manatee
oh she's hitting it oh really
she's interested in the second
episode oh that's so funny i love when
they get real kids to do kid
me too i see a trey parker like a little
video of trey parker putting his kid and
stuff and it just makes me laugh oh
that's funny but does he do one of the
um they do those kids on the the canada
ike i think i can yeah oh that's funny
that makes sense uh why why it sounds so
funny um but i'm so curious why a
manatee
was just like a funny oh they're funny
uh it was literally that it was
literally why not um it was uh
my i enjoy manatees
they're hilarious they're they're
adorable beautiful and yeah uh yeah and
my wife adopted a manatee for me for one
year for like like you know you can like
adopt a star like it's just like yeah
and you just you don't really adopt a
manatee as much as you uh
pay for pay for a piece of paper um that
says you do um
uh but that was it like i just enjoyed
manatees and
always joked around that i was gonna
write a show
called loafy about our manatee but he
was how successful he was and he was a
very famous drug dealer and
uh and then got a phone call i think it
was like imdb it was like uh like they
were like doing this show called oh god
now we're forgetting the name of it is
the one that kevin hosted kevin smith
hosted a show uh i don't think so not
that one no um no no he hosted a
different one
it was about like projects that never
got made and you came on the show and
just told them about it and then like
they animated a little bit of it
and uh comedy central we went to comedy
central we were like we actually kind of
think this is funny and then they ended
up making a couple shorts oh that's cool
that's how fun and you get to do you
improvise a lot of it
uh that was the thing it feels
improvised i loved dr katz uh growing up
yeah right so originally the pitch
was
just
loafie's a manatee who can't leave his
tank he can't leave his tank and he
sells weed so no matter what if you want
to buy it you have to come to him and
that was literally just the whole joke
was dr cat so like we just for animation
we just didn't have to make people leave
they had to it was to sit in one spot
that's perfect but uh and it was just
gonna be that i mean i was just gonna do
a bunch of shorts uh of of like
different people coming to buy weed from
this manatee and talking and it turned
into something very different like that
with comedy central was talking about
making we all tried to make it into a
series so it became like partly scripted
but like
i feel like it was a little weird in the
end it was like half improvised half
scripted and we tried to mix the two but
like if i could do it over again i would
um i love it well now is it totally
scripted is it is it are you
is it that you wish it had you had stuck
to one or the other uh
yes i wish i had just done it completely
uh improvised with just that digital
thing but i do but i do love my little
faith i love i love it oh i bet i'm
doing another one now with them with
them same people called lightning wolves
about thundercat stuff i heard you
somewhere else saying and i now i don't
want to ask um
you were saying you were you you had a
great zoom call i i loved this idea that
you
had like kind of a reunion with old
friends with like high school friends
and like friends you hadn't seen so
great
yeah yeah
yeah no it was i really enjoyed it but i
um
now i'm just gonna wait when did i'm
just gonna rehash everything oh yeah i
didn't even tell my wife that this is a
mine you do a mayan bialik after show
pod
[Music]
yeah it's that i think hers is called oh
my brother's gonna i do the show with my
brother and he's always like don't do
too much he hates when i like which is
what's happening now when i listen to
something and i just kind of rehash what
i've heard and say on other podcasts
[Music]
oh [ __ ] i'm doing it i'm doing it right
now
[Music]
hey life is short listeners i want you
to imagine that you're on a warship in
the final days of world war ii you're
excited to go back home looks like the
war's ending you've just delivered the
necessary parts for the atom bomb
but then disaster strikes your ship is
struck by enemy torpedoes and within
minutes you're floating in the ocean
fighting for survival from wandery
against the odds is an immersive podcast
that puts you in the shoes of resilient
people surviving harrowing ordeals in
their new season you'll hear about the
infamous sinking of uss indianapolis and
the survivors fight to stay alive it's a
fascinating story you probably know the
story of the uss indianapolis from the
famous scene in jaws that robert shaw
recounts um it is harrowing to say the
least sailors who survived the attack
were stranded in the open ocean for
uh five days i believe they endured
brutal weather
rough seas dehydration salt water
poisoning hallucinations and it was one
of the deadliest shark attacks in
history
against the odds has the harrowing true
story of how the brave men of the
indianapolis survived the worst disaster
at sea in u.s naval history listened to
against the odds on apple podcasts
amazon music or you can listen a week
early and add free by joining wondering
plus in the wondery app
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
i have a series of lightning round
questions if you indulge do i do i win
actual cash
yeah it's uh it's we pay you eventually
it's not it's not real cash but it's
it means just donate it to
old people okay okay old drunk please um
what is your most commonly used emoji
your go-to
always in circulation
um i'm you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna
have to say the heart the heart to my
wife
ah there's nothing wrong with that i
just heard i heard a lot of
listeners just doing
doing and eyeing i guess yeah i i
actually went to look
um the second one most used right now is
a birthday cake
oh okay yeah and this one
oh the oh with the eyebrows up yeah like
oh
some not so
big yeah
in what context do you do this one the
the excited the kind of like eyebrows uh
my bobby's
why that's the keenan that's the keen
and special oh
especially
uh that was my favorite thing my
favorite thing to do with keenan in
between sketches literally it's all i
did for nine years
whenever we're just sitting around doing
nothing and we have time i'll go
keenan why don't you just give me a
whoopee 39 and he like i would just
number all of his looks and like there
would be specifics like whoopi 57 is
very different from whoopee 39
and keenan would just give me give me an
is the best it's my favorite he numbers
he has a number for all of his reactions
he's the king of reactions
he does have a great
great face for reactions he is
great and i'm thinking of emojis in
particular like keenan doing emojis is
such a funny idea someone out there if
you're an snl fan and and i i'll i will
actually send you something
if you do this
go out and find every single sketch that
doesn't have a laugh until they cut to
keenan and there's a lot of
i guarantee you there's hundreds that's
funny that's funny it's like an
immediate you just know you're gonna get
something out of it uh yeah
if you could be a professional athlete
um what sport would you hockey
oh for sure i played hockey in high
school
and oh really you were an islanders fan
west east chester rangers
i was a rangers fan uh if if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life bobby
snack food see that's funny you said
snack food and my mind said peach
schnapple but that's not really a snack
food uh you love peach samples love it i
love it i mentioned it
yeah i love it it's my favorite tasting
beverage in the world it's very
different now it's not the same
oh i
was gonna say i haven't had it in years
i remember the kiwi strawberry that was
usually yeah they all go madness the old
glass bottle like seven servings of
sugar per bottle yes apple well
yeah well once i found out that that's
what it was i used to i was
when i was younger i was under the
impression that all juice was healthy
you know yeah i knew nothing about sugar
it was just it was just water
yeah yeah it was healthy it was sweet
freshly squeezed juices
mangoes and madness um
uh
interesting peach snapples but
yeah
um
right now i've been enjoying a little
dull whip have you had those dole whips
no pineapple it's like pineapple ice
cream with with a little whipped cream
on top but and put like also pineapple
juice
so like wow it's almost like a like a
root beer float with pineapple ice cream
and pineapple interesting i know how
much you love movies what is what is a
movie that i'm curious what your
favorite star wars movie is i'm curious
what you're the movie that you were
most
eager to like introduce to your daughter
you know she's for now she's getting to
the age where like she's gonna start
seeing some fun stuff um i can't wait to
show her the tv show lost but like
that's still a long time from now
i feel like yeah huh uh
maybe like eight nine she would have to
be i don't know it's pretty like dark
and weird i feel like eight and nine she
might not i can't wait to watch it with
her when she's like 40.
yeah
yeah
10 years before she discovers life
issues yeah i ca i ca
yeah i can't wait till like
like those things where like she finds
mr show or like she finds party down or
like you know like like just like old
shows that i love that she goes like
what's this like i go like yeah
that you uh some of those people have
held you honey like
isn't that funny yeah oh my god i know i
wonder if she'll be desensitized to that
i always wondered about kids with uh
parents who do do what you do like just
be like oh ted dancer third teen days
after she was born
we brought her on i brought her on stage
with the muppets at the hollywood bowl
no like you know it's like it's like i
know now as like a first-time father
like what the hell was i thinking but
like i also go now like no
i have those pictures i can't wait till
she's 21 and i'm like
my god
yeah daddy did that daddy
what is your favorite star wars movie
i mean i think the first one probably
but like it changes all the time i i
like it's funny now i feel like i just
watched like scenes or like like like
stuff before to be honest i go back and
watch the mandalorian now whenever i
can't oh my god
and all the animated series and stuff i
i like it all i'm i'm more of a fan
i think it's changing and i think now
i'm just like i'm more of a fan of like
the idea of star wars the whole you know
just the idea of like there's this thing
that some nerd created of 20 years ago
that everyone's still talking about and
i really enjoy that is that is that how
you connected with kevin smith you you
mentioned um kevin's well that was that
was uh i was just i mean
i was a huge fan i i i just enjoy i love
that too like i love the idea of like a
guy from new jersey who uh helped his
buddy survive through life
and uh they created this thing together
this universe of their friends and
everybody who like they keep just coming
back and making [ __ ] like it just i i i
that's uh
that's a really cool thing i think uh
he's an amazing dude just for doing that
alone and i think um
the first time
i i i did kevin smith for my audition i
i did silent bob
well no i was terrible at auditions so i
i i had impressions so i the first time
i auditioned not the second time for snl
the first time i auditioned one of my
impressions was i said uh this is kevin
smith as silent bob and i had a baseball
hat with like a wig in it
like already so i just like put it on
and i just leaned against the back wall
and i smoked an entire cigarette and i
didn't say a word you're kidding and
like i just thought that was funny like
i just thought that was the bit was like
that's my impression i literally just
like i i was a smoker at the time and i
just enjoyed a cigarette and laughed at
myself and my mind going like i can't
believe i'm doing this and like that is
crazy bobby that because you described
on i think on stern that atmosphere of
the single light being on lorne michaels
out in the audience and there's a light
on you on that iconic stage how what
what the [ __ ] do you do that that's like
that was like one of the bits i did but
it was just to get out of doing an
impression and
when i i went to comic-con
and it was uh uh jj abrams had like done
this super nice thing where he got me
into that first force awakens panel at
comic-con when it was like the entire
8-h and like at the very end he pulled a
uh andy kaufman and he was like
everybody look under your seats
uh
and everybody looked under their seats
and there was like a lanyard with a
badge in an envelope and he was like
everybody take your envelopes and your
badges and follow these guys and then
all of a sudden like a hundred storm
troopers came in
uh came in the doors and walked down the
aisles and they opened up the side doors
and they were like
please follow these storm troopers to
the san diego band shell where john
williams is going to play the score
of saturday night live and ever all 6
000 people inside this
inside the hall all left to go walk
through san diego and jj abrams was like
come backstage and now i'm standing
there with like harrison ford and carrie
fisher and the entire cast of star wars
and everybody and
and the producers and kathleen kennedy
and everybody and uh
lawrence kasdan i walked up to him and
said hi i was like what the hell's
happening and then i turn around and
kevin smith and jason muse like
and i'm sorry in my mind
jay and silent bob like i'm talking to
the cast of star wars and i too yeah and
jay and silent bob are standing in the
corner and they're both just on their
phones not saying a word to each other
like like and they're acting like
han solo isn't standing five feet away
oh and i remember being super confused
but being like oh [ __ ]
and i ran over to kevin and i was just
like a mess because i had just met all
of these people
and i was like kevin it's an honor to
meet you my name is bobby moynihan i'm
on saturday night live like a child and
just told him that i i did him and he
immediately just cut me off and was just
like
not now buddy
oh really and i was like
what
and i was a little like devastated he
just went not now like super super like
not like and i just kind of walked away
i i'll be honest i don't know if his
words were not now but he was like like
he cut it off and i i just walked away
like what the hell just happened i can
cut see that weird cut to two days later
i'm leaving comic-con
i'm getting on a plane i feel a tap on
my shoulder it's kevin smith
and he's just like i think i need to
apologize to you and i was just like
what's up man like he's like you have to
understand
we were just about to do our panel for
yoga hosers
oh and six thousand people
just left oh he must have been
oh he must have so he was like
everyone's leaving everyone's leaving
everyone's house i was freaking out and
that's when i took his nightmare hi i'm
bobby and i'm a huge fan like
i know i know but and i i know but you
still it wasn't gotta give it up
it was it was an amazing moment who was
your first celebrity crush
wow maybe alyssa milano who's the boss
or kelly bundy
kelly bunny might have been like wait a
minute
yeah girls aren't yeah
um yeah yeah that isn't that funny i
think mine might have been carrying
yeah yeah if you had to get a tattoo
maybe you have them if you had to get
another one
what would you get and where
i haven't gotten one yet i i always
wanted one a couple of the moynihan's
have one um now i always toy i was on
star wars cartoon and he had like a
little symbol on his arm and like i
always toy with getting that but i'm
like
do i really want to do that um
yeah how do you say that also to a cool
like tattoo artist what's that uh that's
my star wars character symbol
um as you probably may have guessed
i definitely sat in south carol south
carolina north carolina north carolina
set south carolina it was south carolina
sat down in a chair and almost got a
tattoo of a giant like a
cheeseburger right here and uh oh
yeah they were like you smell like wait
bye and i was like thank god thank god i
didn't do that oh oh they can do that
they can uh yeah they were like do you
really want this and like they kind of
asked me again and i went thank you for
your time and sheepishly walked out
you
it was like the rudy giuliani moment yes
i guess you know what um i think we all
understand what's happening here
that's a good lack of
um
uh what is your favorite fruit bobby if
you could have any right piece of fruit
uh i want to say what is a quince just
because i never get to say is it quince
a fruit no i just wanted this i think
you say that because of rosy breads um
in white men can't jump what what is a
queen oh really those what is a queen
she was on jeopardy she went what is a
quince i'm sorry oh sorry oh really
my favorite fruit [ __ ]
strawberries there's no they're no wrong
answers you still get paid
in strawberries maybe maybe strawberry
company will approach you um who would
you want to play you and your your bio
pick me yeah yeah of course i know a
whole bunch of stuff who else can do the
bobby moment i would i would love to see
uh i don't know anybody
morgan freeman and like like
actually would probably nail it uh and
i'm so curious to ask you this because
often times people are like uh-huh i
don't know i don't really know the
muppets but i know you love the muppets
um who is your favorite who is your
go-to muppet uh gonzo by leaps and bells
oh really yeah
no kidding
just uh is he one that you identified
with as a kid was there one that you
were like i'm kind of like him
yeah i just always loved
i think like i i think like gonzo has i
i think about it sometimes like when i
get mad at myself i blame gonzo for like
being weird because i go like i just
love the idea that like there was
a character that was like that they
would ask him what he was and he would
say that he was part
law he would just say like i'm part lawn
chair oh yeah he would just say things
that made no sense there was no punch
line it was just weird for weird's sake
he dated a chicken nobody knew what he
was
like he was a stunt man like
yeah that's right he shoot himself out
of cannons he was always kind of in the
way
such an odd
odd but like in his own lane kind of way
yes that's very true they really just
enjoy his demeanor
that's true in fact there's no way to
really like distill gonzo
in a sentence you know there's no way to
like
if you were to just say you know well in
a sentence well who's gonzo it's it's
impossible you'd have to like
do it with what you did just like all
these little attributes like they when
in is it muppets take one of the movies
muppet movie where they're in the crates
and it says like you know he's in the
white crate it's just frog bear other
pig and it just says whatever whatever
yeah yeah it's like that that that makes
me that that makes me laugh yeah totally
um whatever
what is your uh
was your daughter i mean she was how old
i think she was maybe too young but when
she was on stage with the muppets oh she
had did she excited
no she had no idea what was going on no
idea i don't even know if she could see
colors oh she was basil
you're just trying to get it into her
head during her formative yeah so so
what you do is you bring her on stage in
front of 8 000 people and hand her to
sweetums
oh my god that's the big one the big
monster right yeah yeah oh my god
uh that's amazing was the question again
um what's your go-to pizza topping oh uh
straight up cheese
yeah okay i'm boring
and you're in l.a you know yes
yeah i found a couple but it's a little
cliche but it is not a great situation i
know what but if you pizza what's your
what's your what what have you found
that you like
uh all right now pepe's i don't mind if
i'm if i'm in a if i'm i'm in a pinch i
will go very quickly i know it's weird
it's like a chain but i love a thin
pizza i will go pizza aoki that dj
aoki's pizza place oh no
it's good huh he makes a good thin quick
pizza oh okay that's good i didn't know
there was pepe's on the west coast too
because that that's huge here i'm in
connecticut and like people always brag
connecticut yeah does it can you see
where
um
oh that's right that's right because
they had a puppetry program yeah yeah
well and because they had a drama
program they also happen to have that
but yeah
and you love huskies and um
did you ever or or do you ever
think you will get do something with
puppets i mean in terms of oh gosh i
hope i mean like yeah that would be that
would be the greatest i the hosting the
muppet
show getting getting to like do sesame
street and
that was through snl like getting to do
sesame street and then meeting those
guys and nature cat is all uh
david rudman who is cookie monster and
scooter uh uh he's like a big uh sesame
street guy um as well
and kind of building that relationship
with those guys and then getting to go
to
the hollywood bowl and then the o2 in
london and like do the muppet show live
that was the oh my god
it was the the
the craziest i mean like just like yeah
i mean it's nuts it's nuts
i bet bobby um
uh
a few really quick dogs dogs or cats do
you prefer
oh dogs
wait um
what oh this is a terribly long
lightning round i was gonna say no i was
gonna say i like dogs but i think i
would rather own a cat
oh interesting oh that's interesting
yeah only because they're easier to take
care of yes yeah uh that makes sense um
we said the beatles are the rolling
stones um
and if it's
whichever it is is there a song that
you'd really want to hear right now i
mean if you were in a bar if you were
anywhere with the jukebox uh i think i
would go beetles and come together but i
love the rolling stones as well but i
think i would say beatles and come
together just because that song
is great seinfeld your friends
i'll go sign film um and ketchup or
mustard i'm gonna go catch up but i'm
not a big ketchup guy at all oh really
what do you put on a burger or any kind
of vegan cheese you don't like it wet no
no okay no ketchup i don't like ketchup
i mean like every once in a while like i
have to want ketchup i have to go like
i'm in the mood for some ketchup
so i'm gonna put some i'm gonna get some
ketchup and i'll make french fries to
have ketchup with but like
i don't i don't put ketchup on anything
ketchup is the meal for me oh wow okay
well maybe a ketchup company will
approach you let's do it uh bobby last
question
what two adjectives do would you hope
people use to describe you after you've
um left after you've passed on um he's
back
oh
no um those aren't adjectives um no but
i guess it counts yeah
i should have said yeah he's back
and said it positively hopefully
hopefully it's not like ah he's bad i
don't care even if they're upset to have
me back as long as i'm panicking that's
okay i just want to watch some tv i'll
leave you alone
um
i don't know had a good time
yeah something like that well well
this has been a good time um i i
bobby i can't thank you enough i i know
you you're busy and you have the kid
there and so i really appreciate your
time such pleasure it was a blast
[Music]
so that just happened so that i i don't
know
it's hard to an impression of someone
who does such funny characters i know
so that so that just happened i yeah
he's just affable there's an
e you know he's like he said earlier he
is so committed uh and his characters
are so specific that
to just do him is now tricky like bobby
neutral bobby's is tricky
yeah so that happened so that happened
uh i don't know that's just like a guy
yeah i know that's just like a guy yeah
he he's got a really great laugh
such a good laugh oh my god he he
reminds me of someone a laugh that uh of
a friend of mine yes um but it's such a
great laugh you know
what i'm talking about you don't want to
say it it's so joyful yeah yeah it's
it's like bubbly it's like there's an
effort and it gets like when he really
laughs a lot it becomes a little like
maniacal you know but in like a really
joyful way
yes there's a maniacal quality to his
lap
yeah like yeah a little yeah a little
like roger rabbit you don't both have to
think that bobby my hand laughs like
roger rabbit
and he's so sharp you know he's like
yeah he's obviously all those people are
on that show just to some extent but
there's he's so quick like he knows how
to drop in a funny line yes like
whenever it's needed you know he's like
really he's really sharp yeah he's a
great um
he'd be great can you imagine him just
being like the best guy to hang out with
to like um to introduce to a group you
know he'd be great in a group yeah good
asset he'd be a good like socialized
asset asset what'd i say acid
acid that's how you say asset yeah acid
asset acid
acid i
never knew that about you yeah i should
maybe stop saying it or say it properly
what's that i said
it was funny when you
when you said all right i've got a quick
lightning round and
and right away he's so funny and quick
he's like oh do i win cash and i
realized that that's i can't believe no
one's ever said that before on the show
i know it was like
a lightning round it's such a game show
it's true what makes you think of uh
game show lightning rounds now
my horrible performance on family feud
yeah
you know we have to say uh for those of
you who watch family feuds
yeah feudal feudus feudalists uh are why
do i have to make the joke better it
made it worse
that's your instinct that's my instinct
you have to examine some things i do
yeah i should look at that uh
but our friend james duffy
supporter of the show yes um and our
lives he uh
he's not our benefactor no he's
that's like great expectations
um he uh
they cut like we said they cut a bunch
of stuff out of the show but they cut
the funniest thing i think they cut was
when
they steve harvey like asked him a
question in the beginning about what he
does for a living and james was nervous
this was the first time on tv is he
gonna be mad it was his first line ever
on camera
of any sort by the way james is an
editor he's a really he's a wonderful
commercial editor and so he deals with
that world a lot he sees a lot of
performances he sees people on camera
and constantly makes a lot of decisions
about yeah on camera but um yeah never
been on camera and um
except for this uh
mockumentary we made in college called
orgasm about a boy band but anyway not a
lot of people have seen that and until
now until now they're gonna check it out
uh and so j so steve harvey said so
james what do you do for a living and he
was thrown by the question because we
were told that you were going to
introduce your team right all the
members and that's not what happened and
all of a sudden steve harvey's talking
to you yeah you know that's you being
james yes and so james said
[Music]
and he mumbled the word editor and steve
harvey goes in addict
like with this classic like deadpan
delivery
and it was a really funny moment and
james got embarrassed and then later in
the show james's first guest was
a correct one booze
things you keep on hand in case a party
breaks out right in the kitchen
and then then it came back to him and
for that same category and he said uh
drugs
and so
his three moments on that show were i'm
an addict
booze and speaking of drawing stupidly
whoever edits that show cut out the
addict part that would have been such a
funny well through line maybe that that
would have been offensive maybe they
can't show that maybe i i i always think
about that pilot i did sober companion
where they
it was doing well the network but then
they tested it with um certain
groups certain religious groups in the
uh-huh part of the country and they
didn't like it they didn't like any
anything that had to do with alcohol
um bobby moynihan yeah john conquest
speaking of drunk uncle um
so ballsy that he auditioned for snl as
a silence okay i talked to and he just
smoked a cigarette the whole time that
is i mean talk about fearlessness i know
kevin that's the first i saw kevin smith
for i did a little thing clerks three
and i saw him the day after end of the
show friend of the show yes uh
so on the day after i did the bobby
interview and um
and that was the i said oh i just talked
to bobby whatever and you know he's a
fan of yours and and that was the first
thing kevin brought up he was like oh i
heard he did
you know silent bob and um
and and we both were like what ball like
yeah it really is like when you think
about a whole cigarette
smoking a whole cigarette
in silence with lauren michaels like
staring at you and then he told that
story about meeting kevin smith he's a
huge kevin smith fan and how kevin smith
totally totally blew him off you know
he's like not now
because kevin smith was upset that all
the all the star wars people were taking
away his audience for his uh
not now and i thought i can't i can't
believe he's telling this story because
he clearly likes kevin smith and it
makes kevin smith sound terrible
but in kevin's defense
he did come back he apologized and that
to me is that's such an honorable thing
to do you know to like internalize a
mistake
and then reach out to the person that
you offended that should be celebrated
so i really should be i'm glad we're
talking about it me too yeah because
that's cool of kevin smith yes i also
love how much he loves ganzo
is such an underrated i know and it's
it's the perfect he's the perfect muppet
for bobby moynihan
i know they both are like similar energy
like random like weird
and like
and and playful and like game they're
both very game i was watching so it was
weird and you think about gonzo we lose
yeah dating the chicken and he like
works as a stunt man like he does weird
gonzo is weird well he's also always get
his body is always being abused like
he's always getting like
twisted into a pretzel or like also
uh fozzie's a bear miss piggy's a pig
kermit's a frog yeah what is what's
gonzo i'm like that's by me lion that's
yeah the hell is goofy yeah he is the
goofy of the muppets he is that's yeah
that's good line but both have to think
godzilla's the goofy of the muppets but
he is like no one knows what he is i
know yeah he's just like ah that's
something that makes him weird and funny
is that like what is he yeah well he's
like a thing that dates a chicken and
works as a stunt man he could sort of
say that about bobby on snl like what
what exactly yeah yeah i was that was
that yeah that's my point
it's hard to explain him it's hard to
pin him down yes that's true do you want
to read a letter yes okay
all right from kelly whitcomb uh subject
butt stuff oh that's so appropriate butt
stuff b-u-t-t stuff that's the subject
isn't that funny because we were
actually going to talk about our other
uncle who once
shamed oh yeah he he admonished our
older brother for using that when we
were kids for using the word but
remember that i do that's funny yeah
damian was a little kid yeah he was yeah
but but he didn't say butthole no no he
didn't say that whole might have been
worthy of admonishment or like a little
kid i want you to i want to oh yeah of
course yeah damian did not say that
he just said but
okay uh hear me out uh you know what's
funny i was gonna say okay as an okay
back to the letter and here's the letter
okay hear me out
i'm throwing it back to referencing and
that's that's sorry that's a funny way
to start a letter okay hear me out yeah
yes
this is true okay hear me out like it's
almost like it's like they've been
trying to say something
and it's like all right hold on hold on
just hear me out first okay hear me out
i'm throwing it back to referencing nph
episode well you it's a deep cut yeah
it's an old it's the first episode it's
a classic well i don't know it's a
classic it's the first episode it's a
classic to us
back to kelly um oh yeah i'm hearing her
out i thought that and other back to mph
episodes i thought that and other
episodes made my jaw drop from shock but
also informative i love how you all talk
about literally anything
we were talking about buttholes and that
how weird is that oh right do you guys
have a favorite family activity that you
would tell us listeners it sounds like
you have a good family bond and i'm
trying to get that with my current
family oh
a family activity that's a good question
um
i i also like that she thinks that it
might be slightly misleading we have a
good family i mean yeah but we don't
have a specific activity i think our
family get togethers dinners now like i
think most families
in a similar position
uh end up being
everything is about the kids yeah
because they're by far the most
entertaining part of the entire family
now yeah it's a little strange so like
the kids come over and everyone just
play like has fun with the kids yeah and
then like sometimes forgets to talk to
the other adults and sometimes when they
leave it's just like like tumbleweed
like
yeah it's like well it's just us now now
what
there's a little bit of that um dinners
were always really big in our family i
mean like
we had dinner together every night so
sometimes i hear parents say that like
kind of like they're bragging about you
know that they're making this deliberate
choice with their family like we have
dinner every night and that was always
just something i took for granted which
is a testament to i guess the good
parents that we had mm-hmm have yeah um
yeah eating eating it's like a duh but
um and now cooking like i like i i
started being more curious about cooking
and i think that's a nice thing to do
together yeah bonding thing um you don't
really do that with your family no not
really but you eat with them and that i
would say that and um
like having fun with the next generation
yeah are the best activities yeah
playing
playing and eating um i mean what's
better than that
yeah well yeah
um
also not a family activity not a failure
that's okay i should have clarified uh
back to kelly also would you rather's
time great would you rather have
wow there are so many
overlapping things in this letter with
this episode really
here we go i'm going to try to say this
without laughing
would you rather have dicks be the
protein source
so you need to eat one a day
dicks v protein source v like like so
you need to have it i guess so okay or
have screws be the iron source and need
to drink a screw smoothie every day okay
let's let's unpack this um
to eat a dick so
well my first question is yeah i know
does it have to be a human dick oh i
didn't know you're going to say that i
mean i have a lot of things because when
you say eat a dick it's not literal but
in this case it would have it is yeah
you'd have to in fact that happened when
there was a case i think in germany
where a man took an advert took a a
classified ad out
for um they were looking for someone to
eat their dick like literally hmm
it was a fetish very
specific fetish obviously and um and i
think they did it and the man was
i think it killed him but a guy answered
the ad
and and cooked up
did it can you cook it any way you want
uh i
wonder i wonder if he was specific about
how he wanted to cook i guess whoever's
eating it it's up to that well that's my
question if it doesn't have to be a
human dick because then you get into all
issues of cannibalism stuff yeah if it
can be a different animal dick yeah and
you're allowed to cook it however you
want to cook it how would you cook it i
don't know i'd have to i'd have to think
about i'd have to either saute it you
have to really tenderize or broil it
broil it is you get really tender meat
but it's like anything else it's it's
another part of the body so
it might be delicious
yeah
so
if it can be a non-human dick i would
100 percent do that also the screw
smoothie how do you digest is it gonna
is it gonna cut up my insides can i
blend it so it's smooth can i put other
ingredients in the smoothie yeah or is
it just screws because then i have to
taste that metallic yeah we it needs
this needs to be more uh kelly we really
appreciate this and i love the the theme
of it i love like the the
i love it all but but we need more
details on the face of it i would say i
would rather eat a dick every day
okay we'll be right back um what if that
quote is just pulled out
did you ever
think you'd say that sentence
i'd rather eat a dick every day
no
i didn't think i would i hadn't thought
about it the screw smoothie would um
how would you liquify how would you
blend right yeah we love the vitamix not
a sponsor but i love a vitamix and
that's a very powerful it is it might be
able to cut up some screws i doubt it
unless you know they make very tiny
screws have you ever seen like a very
very tiny screw and you could get
through your system yeah
um well yeah i would eat a dick too
justin wants to eat a dick
i always think that tmz i know and the
guy who's like just drinking out of the
cup the with a straw we should get him
on the show
christ almighty um they're like the uh
seven horsemen of the apocalypse
um
what circle of dante's hell would they
be oh yeah that's a good question um
is is gossip is he specific is dante
specifically about like gossip mongering
or that's not one of them it's not right
no what was the top one what was the
highest circle was the traitor uh that
was the lowest and the lowest in the
ninth i think yeah true number one
traitors like it was just like uh lust i
think oh boy which is like you know
every teenager is going to hell right
back to kelly she says love you guys
kelly whitcomb
thanks kelly for um making me imagine
eating a penis
yeah i think i'm really for making me
allowing me to hear you say that out
loud and very definitively that you
would rather eat a dick and if you guys
would like to write in it doesn't have
to be as spicy it doesn't have to be a
bad mix not at all and by the way it
could be from relatives it could be from
dick
uncle dick wants to write in
our email address is life is short
wondery.com and we'd like to thank our
very special very kind very funny guest
bobby moynihan yes bobby uh thank you
and
i'm so glad also bobby thanks for like
are you taking off your shoes now uh my
plunking them on the floor my foot is
falling asleep oh oh my right seems like
such an odd time to do that sorry i'm
like mr rock i'm like you're nothing
like mr rogers oh no that's not true i
mean it's that's so mean
i'm saying right now i know i know well
i am i'm taking off my shoes uh anyway
i hope um i hope you guys all enjoyed
this sorry interrupt you're saying
something nice about poppy what a great
dad he must be i imagine is there a more
fun dad you can imagine i know and that
killed me too that his daughter was like
doesn't want him to do the different
voices oh that's funny he commits to he
just does one that would kill me if like
my kid was like
ah it bothers me when you do different
characters that would be tough that'd be
a tough pill for you i would be
yeah anyway um anyway see you next week
everyone yeah thanks for
listening life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted by you christian
long also produced by you and is
produced by megan v monaco his senior
producer is michelle miesh
and a uh filling in producer is katie
allen
and the audio engineer on this one is
sergio enriquez executive producer is
marshall louis for a company called
wondering wondering hi everyone
[Music]
well that was dark
i thought they just made love
you thought you know that time where i
could find it
they're so nice
oh yeah
i thought maybe i forgot
i'm such a funny alternate ending to
american shoot
chris cooper and kevin spacey just had
like a crazy sex scene and then the
crowds are off
that's funny for your stand-up bet
yeah i guess
it's more it's
i don't i'm not feeling it like it's my
joke though
it's funnier for
you because i didn't know chris cooper
was
oh
that's true
no
sorry
i'm gonna pitch it to justin okay
you